بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين والصلاه والسلام على رسوله
الكريم وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
الرياض الصالحين
الحافظ
الفقيه المحدث الهمام ابو زكريا يحيى ابن
شرف النووي ثم الدمشقي رحمه الله تعالى
معاذ بن جبل رضي الله عنه
معاذ بن جبل مسلم
صحيح
and
he also
is
one of the mers
of what most important party
‏tri
of الانصار you said that's what you say
انصار and he was part of which
group of companions that have a very
specific
deree
when we look at the companions theirit
‏We can kind of look at it almost a
pyramid. The higher we get in
the more
just any virtue the less and less
members of that level of virtue there
are.
‏So if we were to look at the prophets
and messengers we have the prophets
right and then above them we have the
messengers dress the prophets
above them we have the messengers and
prophets that were mentioned in theران
we have the messengers that are
من الرسل messengers
that ‏are the most prominent
most strong and then we have twoah
and محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم we have محمد
here the if we were to look at the
companions
right we have generally speaking the
and then
a level above them are if we say
مهاجرينصار
مهاجرين انصار
بيعه بيعه الرضوان بيعه الشجره
ان العقب ان
الحديبيه بيعه الحديبيه
‏and more
stillag
for parad
by the prop
andous of those are
and
those
علي بن ابي طالب
عثمان
عمر
ابو بكر الصديق معاذ بن جبلز
حلال حرام
بدر
هو بدري
اوكي
معاذ بن جبل
ان ابو ذر ابو ذر جندب ابن عبد الله وجندب
ابن جناده
ابو ذر
ابوذر
جندب
ابن جناده بكسر الجيم
جندب ابن جناده
جندب ابن جناده بضم الجيم
جندب بن عبد
ج ابن السكن
برير بن جندب على كل حاليا
رضي الله عنه ابو ذر الغفاري
‏virtuous not only in
knowledge and his experion but he also
veryous
with to
line
because the prophet محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم
and رضي الله عنه ابو ذر
رضي الله عنه
wasلام
in
لام
وفي بعض الروايات انا خامس الاسلام
[Silence]
هجره مدين
صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلى الله عليه
اصدق الناس لهجه
له
علي بن ابي طالب رضي الله عنه
ابو ذر
وعاء
ملئ علما ثم اوكع عليه فلم يخرج منه شيء
حتى قبض
‏wasover was put
any
passable
comp
عليه وسلم
[Silence]
280 281
‏which is
not a small number when you account for
original narrations because a narration
may have many vari to it it may be
narrated as core concept is this but
then it has many chains of narration and
little variations here and there but all
of those chains of narrations and all of
‏they all are0
رضي الله عنه
توفي رضي الله عنه بالربذه
سنه او
are
so ابو ذر رضي الله عنه was man of great
knowledge integrity
very early
to the point that he
timean
wash personcept
صلى الله عليه وسلم دعوهجره
fromغفاريغفار
هجره مدينه رضي الله تعالى
هجره نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يعلمنا
ما ينفعنا وان ينفعنا بما علمنا نساله
سبحانه وتعالى ان
نساله سبحانه وتعالى
علما نافعا ورزقا طيبا وعملا متقبل بلا
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد
وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين والحمد لله رب
العالمين
[Silence]
الصحابه على
وعلى
الصغار الصحابه يعني اسلم
صلى الله عليه